peu
[Musique]
on sort midam bon sens mesdemoiselles
poncin essieux et voilà monsieur le
directeur
oui c'est plat un sujet pas vous
n'auriez pas un autre plan que ceux
avancés par les sentiments bon alors mon
vieux un peu d'imagination qu'il ya
réalisé deux fois par principe une idée
non oui je m'étais vous les unes à côté
des autres
voilà comme ceci très bien alors
maintenant vous avez les mains une
révérence mais il faut dire bonsoir
besoin un jour tout fait en faudra plus
pour sa remise à vos envies demoiselle
bonsoir messieurs
oui attention c'est que là ce sont plus
des femmes tombent
oui on les a menti oui mais je continue
à trouver ça ces plans vous n'auriez pas
un autre plat on n'allait pas auparavant
we are a pataugé interverti fax et ben
non le lire je visionne le contenu a
trouvé ça assez plat vous n'auriez pas
un autre quand vous appelez ça voilà un
autre clin d'oeil les jours bon c'est
facile alors la caméra au 25 25 quand
même vaste a minima - un train alors aux
25 et 1 sur base une bonne base
classique je suppose reçoit comptez vous
phare mesdames bonsoir mes demoiselles
bonsoir messieurs mais ces places est
encore placer je suis obligé de me
répéter ces places le directeur ses
places à ne même pas drôle non mais là
je parle du texte maintenant non parce
que vous comprenez comme responsable de
cette émission parce que même mois deux
émissions alors je voudrais prendre
congé des téléspectateurs d'une façon un
petit peu original se sortent de
l'ordinaire qui fait alors à mon avis il
faut essayer plusieurs formes excellent
informe une excellente formule alors
essayons mais quoi wa pourquoi et bien
vous savez bien vous allez voir vous
allez voir mais voit alors peut-être
cent écus ou alors jusqu au revoir arras
wii ou encore et voilà ouf c'est fini ou
faisait février à ses pains ça ou alors
ou alors ciao
c'est pas mal ça ou encore salut bonsoir
au plaisir et bonne continuation
peut-être ça non ono non voyons non non
j'aimerais plutôt heureux
bein moi selon good night we 30
je vous livre c'est pas possible son
passé basée à oui c'est vrai que le
shopping nous allons jusqu'à lyon mais
nous ne traversons pas encore le channel
alors attendez attendez je vais me
laisser aller à mon inspiration du
moment je pense qu'elle n'est pas
mauvaise la bougresse attendait c'est
avec une émotion mais les de mélancolie
[Musique]
comme suit en croit que j'ai mon vieux
ou jeunes difficiles ou nuances et de
mélancolie que je vous souhaite à tous
une bonne nuit une bonne semaine vive le
tiers séville le crottin en bleu soyez
ferme sur les prix embrasser nounours et
relaxez vous manger des oranges acheter
une machine à laver et prenez du propage
emportements il y aurait intérêt
bon alors plutôt que de penser à savoir
comment nous allons terminer cette
émission peut-être vaudrait-il mieux
songez à savoir comment nous allons la
commencer oui oui c'est une remarque
judicieuse
je vais regarder dans cette direction
vers le studio a et